en francia en medio del descontento de
los dueños de pequeños negocios que
argumentan que es injusto que tengan que
cerrar mientras que varios supermercados
donde se creería que se propagaría más
rápido el virus permanecen abiertos el
gobierno salió en defensa de las medidas
igualmente no habrá reapertura señora y
veo que todos y todas los comerciantes
tenemos que estar vigilantes y respetar
el confinamiento este ayuda a la subida
de la economía ayuda a nuestra salud
colectiva es imperativo que colectivo se
tan de atención en españa alrededor de
62 personas fueron arrestadas en medio
de manifestaciones en contra de las
medidas que limitan los desplazamientos
y las reuniones sociales durante el
festivo de todos los santos en italia el
gobierno reportó más de 29.000 nuevos
contagios en las últimas 24 horas número
nuevo de contagios más alto desde el
inicio de la crisis sanitaria
italia reporta 709 mil 335 casos
y virus se multiplica el virus se
multiplica a su crecimiento es impetuoso
como nunca antes
es verdad que proporcionalmente hace
menos daño si lo comparamos con la
primera ola pero hasta cuando christina
humery xenón con este número de
contagios si se amplifica la curva de
contagios ningún sistema de salud
incluye el italiano será capaz de
manejar la mano sale de acá para seguir
el sur se suma a la lista ginebra el
gobierno regional decretó un semi
confinamiento durante las próximas
cuatro semanas
europa suma más de 10 millones de
contagios lo que representa el 22 por
ciento de los casos a nivel mundial